his evolution is not a linear one he
changes from light to dark and back
again and the Batmobile changes in shape
and character and power and design again
and again to reflect that
stop
hi I'm Glen Weldon from NPR's pop
culture happy hour I'm also the author
of the Caped Crusader Batman on the rise
of nerd culture today I'm going to be
walking you through every Batmobile from
film and television in this the
Batmobile is basically just a 1939
Cadillac series 75 convertible it's just
a car now to put that in some context
the Batmobile was introduced very early
in Detective Comics 27 and it was also
just a car as started out it was a red
roadster it was Bruce Wayne's car as a
matter of fact and if you go back and
read those early issues they spent a
tremendous amount of time just having
him figure out a place to park it before
he goes and fights crime he hadn't
mastered the whole secret identity thing
yet and the Batman of the serial same
thing hadn't really figured out the
whole secret identity thing yet while in
the comics the Batmobile by this point
was a beast of a car which highly
stylized with a lot of the stuff that
you're gonna see in other Batmobile is
going forward it has a big hood ornament
kind of battering ram bat head it's got
a giant single batwing tail fin and they
could get away with that in the comics
because comics have an unlimited special
effects budget movie serials were made
on the cheap
the way they differentiated it is that
when the top was down it was Bruce
Wayne's car and when the top was up it
was Batman's and criminals recognized it
as such an interesting point is that
Alfred the butler chauffeured both
Batman and Bruce around in that fat now
but drive into that alley and with the
problem doesn't make any sense but
comics don't make any sense I mean
Superman wears eyeglasses nobody
recognizes him Batman puts the top up
nobody recognizes him now at this point
comic book heroes didn't really have
personalities they were just cops and
capes
and in this case in the movie serial
Batman is just a detective just a cop in
a Batman costume never mind you'll find
out and if you go back and watch these
serials there are products at their time
they were made during the war they're
incredibly racist toward Japanese people
pretty good zakir your makeup is perfect
it's anti-japanese sentiment is right
there on the surface
next up the 1949 Batman and Robin movie
serial it's in 1949 mercury again just a
car the same deal as before when the top
is up it's the Batmobile and the top is
down it's Bruce Wayne's whip we look
under that explosion it's Batman and
Robin in the comics at this point the
design of the bat move it was constantly
evolving
can you throw in a mobile crime lab you
throw in a big bubble canopy you throw
in bat wings tail fins that kind of grew
and shrank over and over again it would
take another 17 years before we got
another live-action Batmobile and by
that time the Batman of television had
learned about branding from the Batman
of the comics
[Music]
all right here it is the 1966 Batman
television series Batmobile now I grew
up watching this series in reruns in
reruns and that's why two members of my
generation and those older this is the
iconic the quintessential the seminal
Batmobile
the TV show had two things going for it
the serials didn't one a budget and to
style for days this show arrived at the
height of the pop art movement of pop
art movement value of things that were
slick and commercial and colorful and
disposable which is why they reacted to
comic books and comic book heroes in
such a big way this show became a
phenomenon a fad and everything about it
its iconography the show's sensibility
which is to take very silly things very
seriously doesn't seem to make sense and
especially this Batmobile invaded the
cultural consciousness that became cause
celebs the Batmobiles design here is
based on the Ford concept car of the
future which never went into production
you'll see echoes of this Batmobile and
just about every battement bill that
comes after it you'll see twin bubble
canopies again you'll see at this color
scheme red and black it won't come back
again until Batman Beyond but it's gonna
come back both of those things make this
car seem sporty which is odd because it
is a barge it is a long low rectangle of
heavy steel with no clearance pray that
there's no potholes or speed bumps in
Gotham City it looks great and it is
great going forward in a straight line
but zero maneuverability I mean the
turning radius that on this thing is a
literal joke on the show whenever Batman
needs to make a u-turn
he deploys a couple of parachutes to
turn the car when a van comes the
Batmobile parachute pickup and service
to pick them up which just shows you how
much Bruce Wayne is propping up the
economic infrastructure of Gotham City
now one thing this show did was to take
the comics of the time and play them
very straight that's where the humor
came from Batman and all comic book
heroes were for kids people didn't
really know the character that well
because he was relegated to the comic
books which were read by a few thousand
kids by the time this show ends you'll
see a different kind of readership teens
and adults start reading comics
superheroes get personalities and
personality disorders to distinguish
them one from the other something
besides their costume differentiates
them in terms of their personalities
this Batmobile isn't about performance
it's about looking great it's about
looking powerful and branding alright
this one's from the Batman Superman
adventure hour in 1968 an animated
series this is the first animated
Batmobile and it has echoes of the 1966
live-action Batmobile of course but it's
much sporty-er and it is actually if you
look it's more influenced by racing cars
and sports cars of the time it's got a
very simplified design to make it easy
to animate one flourish which are those
oversized bat wings which are so big
that in the real world they wouldn't be
so much aerodynamic as arrow lethargic
in comics and animation of the time the
technology was such that black objects
lost any sense of texture they look like
black blobs which is why this design
comes with those white highlights it's
that ideal especially if you are having
any scenes taking place at night about
four years later they came up with a
solution Super Friends 1973 notice the
kind of blue are looking at here it's a
very light blue a friendly blue because
this Batman is still the bright friendly
careful gym but history and safety
Batman who works by de Bowser on with
other heroes over the course of his
career in and out of the comics Batman
has cycled through three phases again
and again he's a dark lone Devender of
the night he becomes a compassionate
father figure to Robin and then
eventually becomes a patriarch of an
extended bat family every time he does
that goes through that cycle he lightens
up a bit but eventually he will go back
to being a dark
Avenger of the night in popular culture
up this time in 1973 the 66 Batman and
the 66 Batmobile just hung around
because the show was such a cultural
phenomenon in the comics of course
something much different was going on
the hardcore fans of Batman who read the
comics hated everything about that 1966
show and as soon it was over the makers
of Batman took him back to his roots
that kicked Robin out sent him off to
college and turned Batman into an
obsessed brooding loner back to his
original roots all of the trappings of
the 1966 Batman television series were
rejected there was no more Batcave there
was no more Batmobile the Batman of the
comics at the time as this Batmobile was
on television it was driving a sports
car Riddler must be losing his marbles
everythings he can outdrive me this is
the challenge of the Superfriends from
1978 this is an evolution of the
Superfriends show and here again you see
how big an impact the 66 Batmobile had
it's gonna take something huge something
unprecedented and something that could
make a cultural impact as big or larger
as the Batman television series to get
out from under the shadow of this in
particular design
and here it is the Batman movie 1989
directed by Tim Berkeley
23 years after the 1966 series we got
the thing that made as big a cultural
impression if not larger Tim Burton's
Batman was an event summer of 1989 you
couldn't escape it the bat logo was
everywhere promotional clips of the
movie played over and over again on
television and many of them featured
this film's radical this is back to
being a show of force a power dark heavy
if the 1966 Batmobile had a sullen
teenage goth son this would be it it is
again about design over functionality
this Batmobile was designed by Julian
caldo and Keith Short caldo to the
illustrations and short did the final
body sculpt looks great on the page
looks great on the screen with those
swooping fenders but again no turning
radius to speak of if it needs to do a
quick turn it deploys a grappling hook
instead of parachutes I do have one
quibble and it's a big one it comes with
retractable front mounted machine guns
pretty much the antithesis of everything
the character is about but then so is
Alfred letting Vicky Vale into the
Batcave so is the Joker killing Bruce
Wayne's parents I mean that's Hollywood
now there were fans of the comics of
course who were now teenagers and adults
who were taking a character very
seriously but this was a complete
surprise to normals people who just went
to see the movie had no idea that Batman
was this dark and brooding now because
the last time they had seen the
character he was a joke some days you
just can't get rid of a bomb and that's
what they went in expecting and that's
not quite what they got as the film was
being made hardcore fans hated
everything they heard about it they
hated the armored bat suit they hated
Jack Nicholson as the Joker they hated a
lot of aspects of what they were seeing
when the film came out it was widely
praised even by hardcore bat fans
especially by hardcore Batman's because
suddenly they could share this thing
they loved with people who didn't read
comics or didn't watch animated series
suddenly Batman was the lingua franca
was all over the place he was sports now
and that was a brand new experience all
right this is Batman the Animated Series
1992 if you take the Tim Burton
Batmobile and you flatten it into the
shape of the 66 Batman television show
Batmobile and you swap out all those
swoopy goth elements that Burton put in
and you you go for something a little
bit more elegant more refined more
restrained take Art Deco elements and
there you have it you've got the
animated series Batmobile it basically
looks like if you took the Chrysler
Building toppled it over and put some
wheels on it to tool around Gotham City
now two people who grew up with this
show this Batmobile is iconic to them as
the 66 Batmobile is to me I think that
has something to do with its placement
its prominent placement in the opening
credits this Batmobile comes into your
home every day always in the same way at
the exact same time every episode of the
1966 series started the same way and
when that happens it imprints on your
brain on your very soul Eadie's it's an
almost ritualistic experience somebody
else that has in common with the 1966
series is that it is stylized so heavily
stylized that it ceases to be of a
specific time it is out of time this
show is taking elements from many
different time periods and mashing them
together so it doesn't look dated it
looks stylish
iconic and the elements that it has the
Art Deco elements are timeless in the
1993 episode the mechanic we learned the
origin of the Batmobile looks a little
bit different here this design is one of
the show's many many many homage is to
Golden Age comics when the Batmobile
sported an enormous bat head battering
ram like this one Joel Schumacher took
over the Batman films from Tim Burton
and when he did he was tasked by the
studio with two objectives one lighten
up Burton's kind of dark SNM tinged
universe and to sell some toys he
replaced the somber heavy goth excess of
Tim Burton with a different kind of
excess his very own neon lasers
fluorescent paint he threw in more bat
costumes and more bat vehicles what do
you suggest Alfred
term toy attic comes into play here toy
etic means easily licensed for toys
games and merch I would argue that this
Batmobile is not just toy attic it is
sex toy attic it is undeniably phallic
it is lit from within it is ribbed for
their pleasure
if Vegas was a marital aid it looks
something like this one of the things
about Batman is that he's open to a lot
of different interpretations there's not
one single kind of Batman there's
different Batman's because again he
cycles through various stages Schumacher
is a visual stylist first and foremost a
storyteller second if you're gonna ding
this Batmobile you would say style over
substance but after all the line between
stylish and garish is a very personal
one you can see all the familiar
elements underneath that glamour I think
of this as the Batmobile in drag and I
don't hate it but again in terms of
functionality it's got none it's got a
grappling hook that can allow it to
climb vertical walls what's the exit
strategy there exactly what do you do
when you're in the middle of a wall it's
wheels can pivot to allow for
perpendicular movement and when I check
the wiki there's always a wiki it said
that's explainable by virtue of
hyperboloid wheels on axles I don't know
what that means but it looks cool
Burton's Batman return was so dark that
it was hard to license
materials it was hard to get a deal with
McDonald's because it was such a weird
film so tinged with SNM elements and
they wanted to target more directly to
kids so they turned to Joel Schumacher
who made it very bright and very
colorful and very gay here it's a much
lighter version of Batman because after
all he is mentoring Robin he's a
different fit kind of figure than the
lone grim Avenger of the Burton films
now he's got a kid to take care of so
that brings into it a more kid-friendly
approach
Batman and Robin 1997 we're sticking
with Schumacher again he comes back to
direct this and even more can't be a
more direct homage to the 1966 series
you see the Cyclones turn now this one's
based on a roadster it's a single seater
because by this point Robins got his own
cycle and look how far we've come when
you couldn't even see inside Burton's
battery it was all black mat here the
drivers open to the air just like the
Adam West Batmobile once again the cycle
is turning the batwing tail fins here
are larger than they'll ever be because
this approach show Walker's approach is
about live excess bigger swoopy err
campy ER he's famous for telling his
cast and crew in this film that they're
called comic books not tragic books
which fundamentally misunderstands the
whole what comic and comic books mean
but let that go because that's his
approach he is all about go big or go
home
and no one goes home so once again the
cycle is about to turn this very popular
very fun but much disliked by the
hardcore fans version of Batman has kind
of salted the earth and said well
nobody's can make another Batman film
just like the 1966 Batman series it cast
a long shadow people wanted to get out
from under it and it would take a long
time for anybody to try it again and
when they did they had to radically
revised how they approached him
[Music]
the new Batman adventures 1997 after the
Schumacher Batmobiles any Batmobile
would look like a scaling back anything
will look more grounded this is a very
simplified design but one that will
become part of the DC Animated universe
for a while it's one that Batman used in
the cartoon justice beyond 1999 this is
set in the future time period what
Batman has retired he takes under his
wing Terry McGinnis a young punk kid who
becomes the Batman of this future may be
used to dealing with freaks and monsters
but I'm in the future the Batmobile is
gonna fly because of course it will and
what else do you need there it is very
visually reminiscent of the flying cars
from Blade Runner which is make sense
because a lot of the design aesthetic of
this particular show owes a lot to Blade
Runner it's time people wondered why
this version of Batman the Terry
McGinnis Batman needed a flying car
because he can fly himself that suit
allows him to fly to that I would say
you can walk you also have a car not all
crime happens next door
the Batman from 2004 okay you already
noticed the pendulum is swinging back we
had very light we had fluorescent and
glowing and big wings to something a lot
more compact a lot more powerful lot
less flashy more about sportiness and
performance it's a lot more butch than
the Schumacher bat just that I take it
for a spin and in 2005 they redesigned
the Batmobile for the Batman animated
series the original Batmobile in that
series got totaled so they introduced
this version and here we are again we're
going back out of the sense of fun and
lightness to something much darker much
heavier much more macho black so again
going from light to dark and now we're
back to dark firmly back to dark and
grim and gritty and purely functional
nothing extraneous no design for designs
sake here this is serious this is manly
this is butch this is no fun at all this
is Christopher Nolan the design of this
one I was gonna call it the Batmobile
but that'd be silly because this is
Nolan's stated goal in making this film
was to disavow anything fun or campy
about Batman to dispel the ghost of Jill
Schumacher so it's not called the
Batmobile it's called the tumblr tumblr
was the first thing designed for this
film everything about it in terms of
production design flowed from it Nolan
took a lump of clay shaped it into this
vaguely tank-like shape and gave it to
his production designer to go to town
this is all about practicality and how
we shall force not style armor plating
instead of batwing nothing sleek or
swooping or stylish here this is a
workhorse of pure functionality and
again not to put too fine a point on it
it's not red it's not black it's not
blue it's grey the influence of this
film would be seen for a long time
because public loved it the geeks loved
it everybody came together and said yes
this this is the version of Batman that
I like the thing is though that this
approach works great for Batman if you
try to apply this same approach to say I
don't know let me pick a name out of the
Hat Superman who is about hope and light
the tones don't mesh the the tone of a
dark gritty Batman makes sense and it's
one that has been in the comics since
so it
lines up with the comic book reader
sensibility and it also makes for a good
superhero film for the normals and again
this is why comic book readers really
gravitated to these films in a big way
they said finally this is the version of
Batman we won't
Batman Gotham Knight 2008 this is an
anthology film basically a bunch of
different stories now take a look at
this Batmobile we are reaching a
different kind of extreme instead of
glitzy sleek and glamorous we are now
mashing up a literal fighter jet with a
tank
this is Batman as manly this is Batman
as bro
Batman the brave in the bowl 2008 this
series mission statement was to pay
loving homage to every era of Batman so
you get every era of the Batmobile you
get a golden age back to ring RAM you
get the fenders the single tail fin but
the details and the highlights come from
the classic 1966 Batmobile everything
about this seems more open to me more
playful less defensive less militarized
this is going away from the Christopher
Nolan approaches less insistent that we
take everything about that men very
seriously Batman The Brave and the bold
at 2009 redesigned we're getting even
farther away from the militaristic here
we're leaning harder into the 1940s
specifically the 1940s comic book
version of Batman in every detail this
could have left straight off the book
page of a 1940's Batman Batman under the
Red Hood we don't see a lot of the
Batmobile in this particular animated
film but what we do see is a cross
between the Burton Batmobile and the
sharper curvier lines of some of the
Batmobiles that came after it but of
course it's it's post Nolan's we need
that armor plating everything is about
armor plating
experience the world of Batman like
never before
Batman Live 2011 now not many people
actually got a chance to see this
particular Batmobile because it was
featured in a live stage stunt show that
toured the u.s. in the UK
instead of stylized bat wings you get a
pretty standard spoiler the shape is
more reminiscent of formula racing cars
it's like a broody reversion of speed
racer's Mach 5 by the way in terms of
iconic fictional cars it goes number 5
Chitty Chitty Bang Bang before Herbie
the lovebug number 3 KITT number 2 speed
racer's about 5 number 1 Batmobile
beware the batman animated series from
2013 this is very low and sporty it's
got the curvy fenders of a Formula One
racecar it looks kind of what would
happen if you stuck wheels on the flying
Batmobile from Batman Beyond Teen Titans
go 2013 again we are now seeing the
light to dark to light to dark psychic
speeding up here is an animated version
of Tim Burton's Batmobile just down to
the turbine engine on
where I'm in cloud cuckoo-land will
raise an army of master-builders gotta
check out these new subwoofers I
installed in the back the lego movie
2014 we are now fully back into the
light into the sense of fun to keep up
with the film's very fun fast approach
very fun fast tone yeah it looks like
the tumblr yes it does
tank like but again you got those bat
wings straight out of Joel Schumacher
which make sense it's it's a Lego it's
you can put things together from a lot
of different eras
it's a stylistic mashup really and it
makes a lot of sense no I know how no
son of Batman 2014 this animated film
has a darker tone so it took the
familiar brave of the bold design and
literally dark Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice well we're swinging back to the
grey militaristic armored but this
doesn't quite have the ruthless
functionality of the tumbler there is a
half-hearted attempt at stylisation here
at some familiar bat-like and ography
there's something vaguely gothic about
it but again machine guns it's not the
worst thing about the movie but it is an
ill-considered choice it doesn't make a
lot of sense for Batman it's a violation
of the character but instead feeling
like a synthesis of a lot of different
approaches this thing feels caught
between two different aesthetics is it a
tank is it a race car is it a bracing
tank it doesn't make a lot of sense to
me this film was directed by Zack Snyder
who is a devotee of Iran and you can
tell the dude does not believe in the
whole notion of heroism
it's a rough fit really and that leeches
into the to the design aesthetic of the
film into the grayness of these films
then into every aspect of design
including the Batmobile it feels
hopeless it feels like there's no point
there's no reason to try to save others
because nobody's trying to save you
it doesn't feel like the nolan films but
the nolan films which at least were
about the hero's journey this feels like
what's the point critics didn't care for
this film the public liked it the first
weekend and then not so much a second
this doesn't have a good reputation and
I think it's deservedly so
but that's only one approach to Batman
after all cuz in the Lego Batman movie
you're once again right back into the
light right back into the fund we're
getting tonal whiplash right now this is
a long Roadster not to put too fine a
point on it but the bat mobility we see
in this film is a lot like the
Schumacher film Batman it's a long
Roadster with a single seat a great
honking batwing design and again he
begins the film as a dark grim loner
which is why this Batmobile has a
single-seat cockpit second 2017 gallego
Batman movie by the end of the film he's
back to being the leader of an extended
bat family so everything about this is
bright and light here and in fact the
design of this entire Batmobile is just
a vehicle for robbing a vehicle for
Alfred a vehicle for Batgirl all smashed
together
Justice League 2017 almost an
instantaneous reversion to the light
side no more silliness now we're gonna
take this guy who dresses up as a bat so
he can punch crime in the face we're
gonna take it very seriously say this
much about this version of the Batmobile
in the Justice League film it's a more
effective synthesis of all the
pre-existing Batmobiles the live-action
film Batmobiles it's about 25% Burton
10% Schumacher 65% Nolan and while the
design of the Batmobile is an effective
synthesis the film itself is kind of a
mash-up it feels like it's all over the
place it doesn't feel like the tone of
the Superman matches the tone of bat
it feels like it they're trying to mash
these things together in a way that's
not entirely effective
the eights 5 litre 460 horsepower engine
Gotham in 2018 now this is not an
official Batmobile I won't call it that
because it comes from a show about
Batman before he was Batman so let's
call this the master Bruce mobile it's a
black Ford Mustang that's all it is what
is interesting here is that this is the
Batmobile as a muscle car which it
hasn't been before it's an interesting
concept that's about to get fleshed out
a lot more but not before Titans 2018
the DC Universe show introduced this
version of the Batmobile and it's six
episode and there's nothing new here
that's kind of the point you want it to
be instantly recognizable as the
Batmobile this is not a radical
reinvention basically you're just
doubling down on previous designs the
Batman live Batmobile the brave the bold
Batmobile the under the Red Hood
Batmobile you got the twin bubble
canopies I told you they'd come back and
they did because again the influence of
the 66 Batmobile just isn't going away
the Batman 2021 we've only gotten a
glimpse of this so far it's the one that
will appear in the Matt Reeves film but
what we've seen looks interesting it's
basically a souped up muscle car looks a
lot like a Plymouth Barracuda nothing so
prosaic or militaristic is a tank it's
built for speed and performance and
again branding instant recognizability
you see this and you think Batman we
find ourselves a weird point in the
cycle because again while this looks
like a very serious grounded take on
Batman it's got some really big
stylistic flourishes so if the Batmobile
is representative of how this Matri swim
is going to be then we're gonna find
ourselves kind of at a crossroads
instead of turning a cycle from light to
dark we're kind of bringing in both the
light in the dark at the same time now
we don't have a lot to go on yet but but
just by looking at the design of the
Batmobile it is looks like it's going to
be a very grounded approach a very
practical approach to Batman he's got a
muscle car but there's a lot of design
flourishes which suggests something a
little bit lighter so instead of the
cyclo going round and round as always
has this might represent a synthesis of
light and dark bringing him together the
light fun elements and the dark brooding
elements
so looking at all these Batmobiles over
the year I hope it's clear that it's not
just his car it's not just a gadget it's
part about his character it reflects how
he changes everything again his
evolution is not a linear one
he changes from light to dark and back
again and the Batmobile changes in shape
and character and power and design again
and again to reflect that it's a part of
who he is an extension of who he is it's
also looks pretty cool